"The Batman" was such a big movie that one
of its biggest villains got left on the cutting
room floor – no joke.
Matt Reeves' "The Batman" took a long time
to arrive in theaters, but when audiences
finally got to see it, they were met with
a truly intense version of Batman who is so
consumed by his quest for vengeance that he
barely has time to be Bruce Wayne.
The film has been a huge success upon release,
raking in $128.5 million in its opening weekend,
while earning rave reviews from critics.
The film pits the Caped Crusader against a
Zodiac killer-inspired Riddler who wages a
bloody war on the corrupt members of Gotham's
elite.
Riddler's mission also forces Bruce to examine
his parents' legacy, which is called into
question by Riddler's cleansing crusade, a
wrinkle that adds a nice personal touch to
the sprawling detective thriller.
Thankfully, Batman and the Gotham City Police
Department eventually catch the villain, and
lock him up in Arkham Asylum for his crimes.
But remember, this is a comic book movie,
so we're treated to some obligatory sequel
bait in Arkham when the Riddler meets a version
of the Joker — played by "American Animals"
and "Eternals" star Barry Keoghan.
We don't see much of the Clown Prince of Crime,
but he does befriend his new asylum-mate.
Reeves previously revealed that Keoghan shot
footage with Pattinson's Dark Knight, leading
some fans to decry the fact that these frames
were obviously left on the cutting room floor.
Now the infamous deleted scene has finally
been released, confirming what we suspected
about Barry Keoghan's Joker.
[Laughter]
Although the theatrical cut of "The Batman"
gives fans a brief glimpse of the Joker, it's
very careful not to reveal too much of the
villain — presumably to save the full look
for a sequel.
And thanks to the bright light coming in from
the window behind him, his iconic green hair
is barely visible.
That said, Keoghan's gleefully sinister demeanor
sells it perfectly.
The deleted scene offers a full look at the
Joker, as it features the Bat visiting him
in Arkham Asylum as he asks the villain for
help unpacking the Riddler's sadistic mind.
It's an age-old tactic: Use a serial killer
to find a serial killer.
The whole clip feels like a comic book take
on "The Silence of the Lambs," and confirms
that Batman and Joker have already crossed
paths before.
"Almost our anniversary, isn't it?"
Since the movie takes place in Bruce's second
year of crime-fighting, this line suggests
he went up against the Clown in his early
vigilante days — which is pretty impressive.
As a director, Reeves is clever.
He keeps Keoghan out of focus for most of
the sequence, only revealing the villain's
horrific smile toward the end of their conversation.
It's definitely a unique take on the Joker,
a ghastly visage with full-body scarring.
This new version of Batman's nemesis is also
missing chunks of his trademark green hair.
Arkham has clearly not been kind to him.
Coming up with a fresh take on the Joker was
always going to be difficult for Matt Reeves,
because we've had so many different iterations
of the iconic villain over the years.
From Jack Nicholson's sharp-suited mobster
and Heath Ledger's unpredictable anarchist,
to Jared Leto's tattooed gangster and Joaquin
Phoenix's misunderstood comedian.
Thankfully, the director has already revealed
his inspiration for the Joker in this grimy
version of Gotham.
He told IGN that the villain has a congenital
disease that left him completely disfigured,
and that he's, quote, "very much out of the
Conrad Veidt sort of mold."
Silent film star Conrad Veidt's performance
in 1928's "The Man Who Laughs" was the original
inspiration for the Joker.
Reeves told the outlet,
"He's got this congenital disease, he can
never stop smiling.
And I was like, 'Well maybe there's something
here,' where it's not something where he fell
in a vat of chemicals or it's not the Nolan
thing where he has these scars and we don't
know where they came from."
Reeves is clearly a hardcore Batman fan, and
it's great that he wanted to honor the origins
of the villain in his own way.
"This is very, very personal."
The Joker's startling look also feels reminiscent
of the nightmarish take of the character in
Grant Morrison's "Arkham Asylum: A Serious
House on Serious Earth" — and since there's
an "Arkham Asylum" series planned for HBO
Max, it would be great if Keoghan's Joker
shows up there too.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.